me
ははぁ
はぁ
今日皆さんにお話するのは
3つ
チャンスにまつわる3つの話です
一つ目
チャンスの女神には前髪しかないということ
今となってはこうやってみなさんの前でお話することにもまだんだ慣れてきた
僕なんですがじゃあ幼い頃からそうだったかというと全然そんなことはなかったんです
ね見てみましょう
祇王可愛いですねー19年前
またはもう想像も付かないほど透き通った目が印象的ですが
これから3年後
幼稚園入学したんですがそのとき僕は本当にシャイな子供だったんですね
例えば
幼稚園の園庭でみんなで遊んでいるときとか
まあ教室でみんなでまぁ例えば積み木とかブロックとから遊んでいるときとか
そんな時何をしてたかというと
教室の隅っこの一で一人
家族の写真を見ているような子供だったんですまあ想像つかないですよね
なんやねんとでも実際そんなこともだったんです
そんなボケが変わった大きなきっかけが
マジックショーに行ったことでした
その日のマジックショーは
人体切断のマジックだったんですね
マジック所行かれた方はご存知かもしれませんが
マジックショーってー人体切断が始まりますとその前に
じゃあ誰か今日協力してくれるお友達ませんかあって聞くんですよね
マジックショーですから皆さんマジックを楽しみに来てるわけですから
もちろん前の子供達全員てあげるんですとからこれ手ぇ挙げ程度がいいかなということ
で僕も手を上げてしまったんですよね
ちょっとご想像ついた方もいらっしゃるかと思いますが
するとじゃあそうこの白いシャツ時にちょっと前に出てきてくれないと
当てられてしまったんですね
友達と一緒に遊ぶことすらできない社員の子供ですよ
みんなが見ている前で1人で2位に上がって
人体切断されるんです
やっさすがに無理でしょはい無理でした
実はその日僕は前に出ることができなかったんですね
結局そのままマジック所は終わってしまいました
ん
その日の帰り母がある話をしてくれました
それは僕の祖父に関する話
僕の祖父は実は僕が生まれる前に亡くなってしまったので
直接祖父のことは僕は知らないんですがその祖父が一つ好きな言葉があったんだ
それがこちら
チャンスの神様には前髪しかないという言葉でした
もしチャンスがきたらすぐそれを使うのほうがいいよっ
もしそれをつかまなければチャンスは後ろにいってしまって後から後悔してももうそれ
はつかむことはできない
なぜかというとチャンスの神様の後頭部はツルツルで禿げてるから
つかめなよっ
この言葉を聞いて僕は変わったんですね
小学校になりました
ちょっと大人っぽくなりましたねあの実は一番左は友達なんですが真ん中の2人は僕の
とうとう
です
中井兄弟なんですけどそれを置いておいて
小学校1年生になって秘密基地づくりをクラスのみんなでしたことがありました
名前はし美レンジャー
何かお気づきの方もしかしたらいらっしゃるかな当時流行っていたのが
特捜戦隊デカレンジャーご存知の方いらっしゃいますか
ちょっといらっしゃいますありがとうございます
まああいつらがでかなら俺らはチビやろうということでまぁ小1ですからね
し美レンジャーを結成してクラスのみんなで活動したり
あとは小学5年生の時にクロスワード友の会という会をクラス立ち上げまして
クロスワード雑誌って検証がついているんですよねーは一人で応募しても動作わから
ないからみんなで協力してやって当てようぜという企画をクラスのみんなで行ったこと
もありました
みんなと一緒に遊ぶことさえできなかった子供が
クラスのみんなを巻き込んで新しい活動を始めるまでに
だったんですね
そのうち僕はこの事って
3つの ch だらせるんじゃないかなって気づきました
チャンスをキャッチつかむことでチェンジ変わることができる
最初は何にも知らないなんにもできない真っ白な自分でも
あるチャンスを経験することによってそれをつかむことで新しい自分に進化することが
できるんですね
また
チャンスをキャッチ掴み中に変わると今度は
新たなステージに進むことができます
その新たなもっと広いステージでは
違う色のチャンスがやってくるんですね
そしてそのつかんだ違う色のチャンスによって自分をさらに進化させることができる
このことに気付いて僕はもっとチャンスをつかみたい
そう毛布上になりました
その結果が
まさにチャンスをキャッチつかんでチェンジ
変わることで今度は
中学受験をしてみたいと思ったんですね
当時
たまたま仲の良い友達が中学受験をするという話を耳にしました
そこで
何か面白そうだなと思ってやってみたいと思ったんですね当然家族は大反対親戚中大
反対でした
なんで勉強なんかそんな事件勉強6受験戦争とね
言われていた時ですからなぜしないといけないんだとても僕はやりたかった
だからそのチャンスをつかみたいと思った
その結果チャンスを掴むことができて語っ中学校神戸市の私立の学校に入ることができ
ました
中学校に入ったあとは
クラブ活動を選ぶんですがなんとラグビー部に入りましたこんなからでラグビーやっ
てるのかやってるんですよそういうことじゃもあるんです実は
当時ラグビーのイメージといえば3型きつい汚い危険
まあ危険なスポーツですからねラグビーってそんなマイナスのイメージしかなかったん
ですがたまたま
これもたまたまなんですか近所の先輩が実はラグビー部
実はポカリを追ってもらったんですよその先輩に
断るに断れなくてラグビー部に入ってしまいました
でもその経験その決断ですごくよかったんですね
高校1年生の春にラグビー部でイギリスに遠征に行くと言う
まあ中こうラグビー史上唯一の機会があったんですが
そのチャンスをつかむことができてその結果初めての国際交流という経験をすることが
できました
これがもしかしたら今の自分にも影響をもたらしているのかもしれません
ラグビー以外では
生徒会活動も行なっていました
中興の生徒会長を務めていた僕は学校内でのはちゃんとまつかんだわけですが
今度は
全国の生徒会の役員の子たちと一緒に全国高校生徒会大会というイベントを開催する
ことになりました
このことによって学校内で得たチャンスを今度は日本中の同じ志を持った高校生と一緒
に
活動するこういう新たなステージに自分を導くことができたんですね
生徒海外では
模擬国連という活動していました模擬国連とは高校生が2人一組になって
国連大使になりきってある国際問題についてディスカッションをするという大会なん
ですがその模擬国連の大会に出ました
これは教室に貼ってあったチラシをたまたま目にしたことがきっかけでその結果
全日本大会日常 c 最優秀賞をいただきました
そして
世界大会に出場することになったんですね
今思えばこの世界大会で優秀賞を受賞したんですがそのことが今の自分自身の大学にも
大きな影響をもたらしているなと思っています
こうやってこのチャンスの神様には前髪しかない
この言葉を僕はずっと胸に中興6年間
歩んできました
その激化あの日中学受験をしたいと思ったことがきっかけで東大という新たなステージ
にそして
いろんな課外活動やっていろんなことを経験してきたことがきっかけ
ハーバードというもっと広く大きな舞台に自分を進めることができたんですね
これが一つ目の話です
二つ目二つ目は
チャンスを選ぶということ
ハーバードに入って
気づきました
ハーバードってチャンスが多すぎるんですねー
ハーバードはチャンスが多すぎるし
55件今なにかと思うんですがメールの件数です
朝起きて
授業終わって帰ってくるとすぐメールボックスが山のようになっている
ねっ
例えばイベントの紹介とか新しいクラブ活動の宣伝とか
インターンシップのショップ紹介もそうですかそういういろんなチャンスが幅をって
あるんです
もちろん
学生の本分勉強しなきゃいけないですよねそして友達と遊ぶこともしないといけない
じゃあどうしたらいいのか
ここで大切になってきたのがこれ
choose 選ぶということでしたん
じゃあどうやってやるのか
もちろんも決まってますよね立大学生ですよ
はい履歴書に書けるようなことをする
じゃあこれやってたらが就職に有利かなとかここでこれ作った大事かなとか
もちろんそういうことを考える理由はなく
3つのことを僕は考えました
一つ目が好きなこと
二つ目が得意なことそして3つ目が
面白いことな関西人です金をもらうことしか考えてないんでものすごいこともして
みよう
この3つをほか考えて自分のチャンスを選ぶということをしてきました
ん
でも
将来の夢とかそういうことにつながることをしなくてエンター
ないかとしないといけないんじゃないかと思う方がもしかしたいらっしゃるかもします
してません
そんなとき実は僕ばこれ環境政策ということにいますご興味があってそれを将来もやり
たいなと思っているんですがこのほどって実は好きであったり得意であったり
また面白かったりそういうことから生まれてきた自然に出てきたものなんですね
だから
そういう将来の事っていうのはこの好き得意そして面白いこの3つから自然に出てくる
もんじゃないかなって僕は思っています
これが二つ目のエラということについての話
最後3つ目
チャンスに選ばれるということ
ハーバードには全世界から1600人1学年1600人の生徒が集まります
もちろんアメリカですからイギリスカナダ中国韓国
そういう有名どころもそうですが
例えばオーストラリアも大きいですよね大サラリーや南米はブラジルとかもいます
アルゼンチもいます
ヨーロッパに行けばもどういってフランスがもちろんなんですが
ルアンダといったアフリカからも制度が来るんですね
バックグラウンドも様々です例えばケネディの親戚
アメリカ第二元大統領のケネディの親戚が普通に歩いていたりと有名な学者の娘が普通
にクラスメートとして存在したりはたまた
農場で農作業をずっとしていた子がいたり
本当にたくさんのいろんな人がいるんですその中で自分という存在をどういうふうに
アピールしてどうやってチャンスに選ばれないとい選ばれたらいいのか
それがハーバードに入って一番悩んだことでした
そこで東大と比べたいんですが東大とハーバード一つだけ大きな違いがあったんですね
これが東大
見てくださいね
これがハーバード
チェア分かりましたか
いやまぁそのあれですよあの男の高ばっかりとかじゃなくてこれは男子寮なんで
たらいいんですけど
何が違うかというと
東大では
真ん中の一番最前列にた僕がハーバートでまぁ
左の隅っこにですね左から3番目です
これってどういうことかというと
やっぱりいつも場の中心にいた僕でもハーバードでは全然相手にされない
もちろん自分のことを誰もしれないという環境っていうのもあったと思いますでもそれ
以上に僕にとって大きかったのが
英語だったんですね
大阪で18年間僕は生まれ育ちましただから曲市場ではありません
英語といってもネイティブにも到底おりませんし曲集人も全然を
及びません
だから
例えば英語のクラスのディスカッションでもついていけないことたくさんありますし見
たこともないような評価をエッセイでされることもあるんですね
もちろん友達とよくまラグビー部の友達があのー
スラングで会話するんですがわけわからないですね
そうやって英語という壁って僕にとってすごく大きなコンプレックスになっていました
じゃあこの英語という壁を乗り越えてどうやってやっていけばいいのか
それが3つですまた3つ一つは好きなことを使う
好きなことを使って何とかチャンスに選ばれよう僕の場合それば
中興明日ラグビーだったんですね
二つ目得意なことを使えばチャンス選ばれるんじゃないかな
僕の場合それば
写真でした
そして3つ目これがちょっと違います3つ目は
他と違うこと
他人と違うこと
僕にとっての周りと違うことって何だと思いますか
それがまさに
ずっとコンプレックスとして悩んでいた英語だったんですね
僕にとって英語本当に苦手なものでした
でもこの英語が話せないおそらくハーバード1602中で一番離せないと思うんですが
その英語が話せないという事実つまり
大阪で18年間生まれ育ったっていうことは裏を返せば大きな強みになったんです
なぜかというとそれは誰よりも日本らしいということだから
この3つ好きなこと得意なことそして周りと違うこと
この三つを使って僕はいろんな活動に参加してきました例えば好きなことを使って
ハーバードのラグビー部に入りました
二つ目写真得意なことを使ってハーバードの学生新聞のカメラマンを増しています
それによっていろんなイベントに呼んでもらえるようになりました
そして三つ目
周りと違う日本人だしたというところを使って学生会議のオーガナイズを今しています
これによって自分は英語ができないからって諦めていた
その海外の学生と一緒に仕事をするということもできるようになったんですね
こうやってまさに
チャンスを中今度は選んでそしてそれをつかむことで変わることができる
九中図が
4位同じ c 値を持っているって事は偶然じゃないなって僕は思います
こうやってハーバードに入ってチャンスを選ぶということを知った僕ですが実はこの事
ってハーバードに行く前にやってたんですね
ハーバードの受験のプロセスはテストの点数だけではありません
総合人物紹介ですつまり自分がどういう人間でどうやってハーバードに貢献できるの
かっていうことが問われるんですが
そのプロセスにおいて自分の強みはなんでどういうふうにそれをアピールしたらいいの
かということを徹底的に考えたんですね
今思えばこれがハーバードに入ってから生きたんだなと思います
このことを後輩にも伝えたいということで今現在僕は npo 法人
留学フェローシップという団体の代表理事をしています
この龍ゼロは海外進学を目指す高校生のサポートする団体です
自分の強みって何だろうとかそれをどうやってアピールしたらいいんだろうとかそう
いうことを
方向性と一緒に日々考えながら活動しています
こう振り返るとまさに
母が教えてくれた言葉チャンスの神様には前髪しかない
この言葉が僕の今までの人生を大きく支えてくれてそして
後押ししてくれたんだなと思っています
この言葉を教えてくれた家族には本当に感謝していますし
そしてその感謝を忘れずに今度はもっともっと広く大きなステージで
羽ばたいていきたいなというふうに思っています
これが僕のディアーですありがとうございました